one week from today NASA said to launch
a unique space mission that may
revolutionize our understanding of the
Sun the Parker Solar Probe will fly
straight through the sun's outermost
atmosphere the first spacecraft ever to
do so and somehow it won't melt the
roughly 90 mile mission has another
distinction as well the probe is named
for a 91 year old living scientist a
first in the history of the u.s. space
exploration Mary Peterson has the story
two firsts here the first ever probe to
explore the Sun
and the first time NASA is named a
spacecraft after a living person to
present you with the very first scale
model of Parker Solar Probe this living
person Jean Parker who kept for sure a
91 year old astrophysicist at the
University of Chicago you look at this
figure here and you realize there's only
one solution that goes from zero
philosophy to zero pressure
Parker's love affair with astrophysics
started in high school after earning his
ph.d he came to the University of
Chicago as a research associate in 1955
then in 1958 he proved that the Sun
emitted more than heat it also sent out
supersonic streams of charged particles
what we now call solar wind it was
inspiration followed by a lot of mental
sweat and it took me two years to figure
it out Parker had seen the same clues
everyone else saw Earth's atmosphere
bombarded with the solar radiation
commonly known as the Northern Lights
and how in comets passed through the
solar system the tails were always away
from the Sun because Parker suspected
the solar wind blew them outward but
when he went to publish his formula he
was first met not with acclaim but scorn
so when you did this equation and your
critic said you're you should go back to
the library and study something else
were they able to take anything apart in
this no they simply declared the whole
notion was ridiculous and if you pressed
them they would say well it must be you
must have made a mistake here because
it's a review came to a ridiculous
conclusion but nobody who said that was
able to deconstruct this equation to
prove it wrong they didn't even try as
far as I know Parker
visited his namesake as it was being
readied for launch he praised the people
who designed all this
just as many of them consider him a
science superstar I've actually
the respect that has been shown to you
is extraordinary my favorite line
you're like the Brad Pitt of
astrophysics do you feel like Brad Pitt
I'm not entirely clear well let's just
say he's very famous and very handsome
the seven-year 1.5 billion dollar
project will measure the supersonic
speeds if the solar winds the Sun may be
the only star within our reach but
because the Sun is an ordinary star and
if any other star of the same class will
have the same features does that mean
that what we learn from this probe will
tell us about all the stars in the
galaxy the majority of the stars in the
galaxy do you ever stop to think how you
changed our vision of what the Sun is no
but even a hero astrophysicist who
changed the way we see the stars you
know here is the key to it
how's his limits when it comes to
something closer to his earthly home see
that like his hometown Chicago comes
easier to understand the Sun than
predict the optimal baseball game
absolutely baseball game is infinitely
more complicated and involves factor is
about which you know nothing how does
this or that pitcher feel on the morning
of the last game and so forth and so
forth and as the Solar Probe begins its
voyage his lifetime voyage of discovery
has not ended
I've always enjoyed learning how things
work simply endless puzzles and problems
that come to light some of them trivial
amusing some of them very important and
I take great pleasure and in learning
them and because of him we will learn
about our own son and that will teach us
about all the stars that stretch to
infinity for CBS this morning Saturday
Barry Petersen Chicago well that's just
cool Eugene Parker you've got a fan here
now forget Brad Pitt of astrophysics
he's just the Eugene Parker physics